Ronnie turned 70 it kind of blew my mind
I was in race cars this weekend drive
them in 170 miles an hour man where were
you my friend Owens Pocono Raceway so
Stephanie arranged with him in the
school a stock car experience to open up
the track for us it was a lot of sexual
activity oh yeah a lot
oh yeah track so because it was your
birthday weekend was the sex special it
was all about me look what do you mean
like anything I want to take me back the
birthday weekend starts when Thursday
night we had a late dinner and then we
went up to the room and then it was a
quick one I [ __ ] it with my party hat
see Thursday night you [ __ ] right you
get up Friday morning we went to the
track you braced the cars you're going
around that's till about two o'clock Wow
at two o'clock you get done back to the
hotel you all jazzed up from driving the
car first and what happened that's when
you have what all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
what kind of crazy [ __ ] what done you
know [ __ ] rings yeah what was crazy
there was this crazy position we tried
what did you try tell me 70 years old
she has this thing now because she's
working out with this trainer yeah she
flips her legs all the way back behind a
head yeah and like a [ __ ] is standing
straight up in your head kind of right
so it's kind of like jackhammering yeah
what are you doing call it the Mary Lou
I'm Jack Cameron you're standing up but
like like I'm standing over her Wow I'm
drilling tsk well Robin you understand
that yes it's a position where because
her legs are all the way up above her
head right her butt raises all the way
up the bed and her [ __ ] is now flat
like flat like the bed yeah I was Ronnie
doing Ronnie gets on top and he's pile
drives straight down child like
impounding a post and you I don't and
then we took a nap
I bet then took a shower right then I
took a nap again and then and then we
went to dinner with our friends right
and then we came back and [ __ ] again
Wow Wow
after dinner mother [ __ ] you're on
fire two times in one day and the night
for that's three right the day before
you birthday he must have [ __ ] that
was last night
ah no [ __ ] yeah it was kind of anal
my version yeah yeah my version what's
your version well you kind of like get
you thinking this is yesterday last
night what was happening you were just
laying there and she was what were you
watching TV she had tape this is us so
what you start rubbing your dick against
our ass cheeks in between in between are
like in her [ __ ] right but not as a
hawk right but not in our it's like a
drive-by yeah I kind of like it
are you able to come that way yeah oh
yeah and you don't even put it in you
just rub back and forth
yeah it's kind of like jerking yourself
off in her ass what a lot we do on this
guy yeah shrieks are like a [ __ ]
sandwich if she continued to watch this
is us during this well yeah yeah it
doesn't even slow down I couldn't even
hear the [ __ ] TV which is good he's
like an animal
he's like a caveman it's unbeliev falls
watching TV yeah yeah
does she moan at all during I think is
she sports during the commercial break
she paused the TV while you're cleaning
up at all nothing like she keeps
watching she's watch sometimes she has
to fought out my comm but it's always
cool no not in there no no I would think
there'd be no more jism left you know
the guy you're talking about [ __ ] and
[ __ ] like a where's the bit the one
last night was the best load I dropped
the whole weekend I think really yeah
tell me ask you something tease your
actual birthday yeah
is there anything special gonna happen
to my clan I got this really like wrote
the rolls-royce of [ __ ] rings somebody
gave you that well it's got this thing
on it with all these little like prickly
things
uh-huh that it kind of like grabs her
[ __ ] - oh boy it's got Bob's on and it's
got Barb's and it's very tight so you
could stretch it uh-huh
does it have bluetooth my started a it's
it's a special rolls-royce of [ __ ] rings
because it grabs her clitoris yeah and
got these little prickly things on it
sounds like a weapon so when you turn on
to vibrate a part of it that you
actually plug in to recharge oh wow
that's Oh like a high-end deal FBI is
beating or whatever it is yeah yeah the
US will you also got air conditioning